Hey Leute, wir haben heute die passende Antwort auf die Frage "was koche ich nur heute?". Mit ´wir´meine ich natürlich Hamza und mich.
falls ihr euch mal wundert wenn ich in der wir form spreche obwohl ihr nur mich seht.wie auch immer ,ich habe hier überschaubare Zutaten denn wir machen eine klassische
Nudel-Hack-Pfanne
bzw ich verarbeite es weiter als Auflauf, ich überback das Ganze, aber das könnt ihr hier bei dem rezept selber entscheiden wie ihr das macht
und hier sind die Zutaten. Ich habe hier einmal Rinderhackfleisch, Mozzarella zum überbacken. Außerdem habe ich hier Zwiebeln und Knoblauch,
Passierte Tomaten,
Sahne, da nehme ich gerne die fettarme Variante, ein paar Gewürze
Kurkuma, Curry, ein bisschen Chilli, Kreuzkümmel und Zucker und natürlich die Klassiker Salz und Pfeffer. Und was ich auch schon
vorbereitet habe... das sind hier die Nudeln, die müsst ihr ganz einfach nur al dente kochen nach Packungsanleitung
und wir gehen jetzt rüber zur anderen Pfanne und dann zeige ich euch wie wir weiter vorgehen-
Das Öl habe ich hier in meiner beschichteten Pfanne schon erhitzt und da gebe ich jetzt die Zwiebeln mit dazu und auch schon die
Knoblauchzehe. Ihr könnt natürlich auch zwei Knoblauchzehen nehmen. ich bin ja Fan von knoblauch,
aber wir machen es heute mit nur einer
und ihr könnt es dann so ungefähr ein bis zwei Minuten lang auf mittlerer Hitze andünsten und dann kommt das Hackfleisch dazu.
So meine Lieben, nachdem ihr das Fleisch schön durchgebraten habt, das hat so ungefähr 4 - 5 Minuten gedauert auf Stufe Sieben von Neun
gibt ihr alle anderen Zutaten mit dazu bis auf euren Mozzarella, das kommt gleich erst zum Einsatz.
Das heißt passierte Tomaten, die fettarme Sahne und die Gewürze und dann lasst ihr das nochmal fünf Minuten lang
köcheln und dabei immer wieder umrühren
Jetzt habe ich die gekochten Nudeln noch dazu gegeben und jetzt habt ihr zwei Möglichkeiten: Entweder ihr verspeist das so, denn so ist es eigentlich
auch schon fertig oder ihr mögt es wie ich überbacken,dann gibt er das in eure Auflaufform.
Die habe ich hier und dann gibt ihr den käse eurer Wahl darüber. Hamza: Bei uns ist es?
Kiki: Bei uns ist es Mozzarella heute.
(Musik)
Den Ofen habe ich gerade schon
vorgeheizt auf 200 Grad Ober und Unterhitze. Da gebe ich den jetzt nur so lange rein bis der käse wirklich schön schmilzt. Das dürften
so zehn bis 15 minuten sein und dann sehen wir uns auch schon wieder, denn dann können wir auch schon essen
Am besten passt dazu übrigens ein schöner frischer Salat und dann lasst ihr euch das ganz einfach schmecken so wie wir beide gleich nachdem wir die
Fotos geschossen haben
und dann hoffe ich natürlich dass ihr mir ein Däumchen nach oben da lasst, wenn euch das Rezept gefallen hat. Schreibt mir auf jeden fall
mal einen Kommentar was ihr als nächstes sehen möchtet so im herzhaften
Bereich. Gibt mir da gerne mal eure Vorschläge rein und dann halte ich mich da auch dran und dann hoffe ich dass wir uns auch
beim nächsten Video sehen. Tschüss eure Kiki !